i'm richard
what's your name mayor give it up
for miss lady hawk herself
why do they call you a lady hawk i made
a shot in a basketball game
25 years ago they think you're a hero
i love it look at that it must have been
some shot
most places no around here
yeah what do you do mayor i'm a
detective
a detective you don't have any bodies
hidden under your porch do you
uh not yet no
the east easttown police department
received a call reporting a dead body
in freedom creek get that son of a
who did this
cause if you don't i'll kill him myself
tell me about your father he was my best
friend
he passed away when i was 13. he was a
detective
at least you still got your mother oh we
can't stand each other
i can feel it happening again
this expectation from people to be
something i don't think i'm good enough
to be
mayor i know what you've been through
and i know you're worth saving
the ground is just falling out beneath
you mom we don't know what's gonna
happen all right
go back to the file dig deep recommit
yourself
doing something great is overrated
[Music]
people expect that from you
all the time
you